You've made it to the end of this course on translucent materials and visual effects.
Congratulations, and thank you for being part of this class.
Let's take a moment to review what we've learned in these past lessons.
First of all, we explored the world of translucent materials,
familiarizing with the Fresnel and
refraction indexes to achieve the looks and effects we wanted.
We also learned about advanced nodes like the bump offset and the spiral blur.
Further on, we looked into the two-sided foliage shading model and
set up a material with a cute little wind effect on its lips.
But you could really use the simple grasswind material function for
other things like blankets, flags, whatever you want.
Lastly, we developed a dissolve effect using a material function,
reviewing again how to deal with function inputs in that specific case and
get that set up.
Thank you again for sticking around.
I really hope you've enjoyed this course and learned a few tricks from it.
You're welcome to take a glimpse at the other courses on our platform
to further expand your understanding of the engine.
Have lots of fun tinkering with materials in Unreal, and I'll see you soon.
Bye.